das saarland ist das gallische dorf
unter den deutschen bundesländern am
rand gelegen französisch angehaucht
eigen und liebenswert rund
750.000 wählerinnen und wähler das
kleinste landesparlament aufstieg und
fall liegen dort heute nah beieinander
der triumph der anke rehlinger ist auch
der absturz des tobias hans im saarland
haben sich nach 22 jahren cdu-herrschaft
die verhältnisse umgedreht die
spd-spitzenkandidatin beackerte
beständig das landkreis große bundesland
während der nachfolger von annegret
kramp karrenbauer mit seinen vielen
bundesweiten auftritten eher distanz
aufbaut zu glatt auf der seite söders in
der korona politik zu widersprüchlich
tobias hans konnte der cdu kein profil
geben für die christdemokraten fängt das
wahljahr 20 22 schlecht an in kiel will
mit daniel günther schon in sechs wochen
ein ähnlicher politikertyp wiedergewählt
werden die spd spürt heute rückenwind
2017 kamen der schulz zog im saarland
ins stottern jetzt sechs monate nach der
bundestagswahl kann sich auch olaf
scholz bestätigt fühlen dazu beigetragen
hat ausgerechnet oskar lafontaine der
immer unvollendete der deutschen politik
hat zuletzt die saar-linke in den
abgrund geführt ihre wähler haben sich
heute neu und das heißt auch zurück zur
spd orientiert anke rehlinger wird nach
drei eher schwierig und giffey die
vierte sozialdemokratische
ministerpräsidentin vier von acht
trainingserfolg vergrößert nicht nur die
macht der spd im bundesrat er zeigt auch
das größte manko der union anders als
asterix und obelix brauchen cdu und csu
jetzt keinen zaubertrank sondern auf
bundes wie auf landesebene ganz einfach
nur mehr frauen